FIRST IMPEACHMENT TRIAL AND HIS
FAMILY SAID HE DIED OF
COMPLICATIONS TO SURGERY.
>>> A DAMNING PICTURE OF TWITTER
LACK OF SECURITY.
THE FBI THINKS TWITTER MIGHT
HAVE A CHINESE GOVERNMENT SPY ON
THE PAYROLL.
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND FORMER HEAD
OF SECURITY AT TWITTER MADE THE
FIRST PUBLIC APPEARANCE SINCE
THE REMARKABLE ALLEGATIONS
REPORTED BY CNN LAST MONTH.
IT MAKE MAY SOME USERS SECOND
GUESS LOGGING ON.
>> I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE
TWITTER LEADERSHIP IS MISLEADING
THE PUBLIC, LAWMAKERS,
REGULATORS, AND EVEN ITS OWN
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
>> Reporter: FORMER HEAD OF
SECURITY WITH A STARK WARNING
FOR LAWMAKERS.
>> IT IS NOT FARFETCHED TO SAY
THAT EMPLOYEE INSIDE THE COMPANY
COULD TAKE OVER THE ACCOUNTS OF
THE SENATORS IN THIS ROOM.
>> Reporter: FORMER TWITTER
EXPECTATIVE PAINTING A PICTURE
OF A CORPORATION THAT HAS A
DANGER TO NATIONAL SECURITY AND
DEMOCRACY.
>> WHAT I DISCOVERED WHEN I
JOINED TWITTER IS THEY'RE OVER A
DECADE BEHIND INDUSTRY
STANDARDS.
>> Reporter: TEENAGERS HACKED
THE ACCOUNTS OF SOME OF THE MOST
FAMOUS PEOPLE IN THE WORLD AND
THE TESTIMONY A MONTH AFTER
STEPPING FORWARD AS A
WHISTLE-BLOWER WITH CNN AND "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
READY?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS TOO MANY
TWITTER EMPLOYEES HAVE ACCESS TO
THE MAIN CONTROLS.
>> WHAT I DID NOTICE ACTING
BEHALF OF A FOREIGN INTEREST IT
WAS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT TO TRACK
THE PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: LAST MONTH A FORMER
EMPLOYEE CONVICTED OF SPYING FOR
THE SAUDIS.
TODAY HE SAID THAT THE FBI
NOMARED TWITTER OF A CHINESE
GOVERNMENT SPY ON THE PAYROLL.
>> LACKED THE FUNDAMENTAL
ABILITIES TO HUNT FOR FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND EXPEL
THEM.
>> Reporter: TELLING LAWMAKERS
EXPECT I HAVES DRIRN BY PROFIT
NO MATTER THE SECURITY COSTS.
>> I'M REMINDED OF A
CONVERSATION WITH AN EXECUTIVE
WHEN I SAID I'M CONFIDENT WE
HAVE A FOREIGN AGENT AND THE
RESPONSE IS SINCE WE HAVE ONE
WHAT DOES IT MATTER IF WE HAVE
MORE?
LET'S GROW THE OFFICE.
>> Reporter: HE SAID THE FTC
SUSPECT UP TO THE TASK.
>> I THINK THE FTC IS A LITTLE
OVER THEIR HEAD.
THEY HAVE COMPARED TO THE SIZE
OF THE BIG TECH COMPANIES AND
THE CHALLENGE THEY HAVE AGAINST
THEM THEY'RE LEFT LETTING
COMPANIES GRADE THEIR OWN
HOMEWORK.
>> Reporter: JAKE, WE HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM EXECUTIVES ON THE
RECORD SINCE HE WENT PUBLIC A
MONTH AGO.
THIS IS WHAT TWITTER SAYING IN A
STATEMENT TONIGHT SAYING THE
HEARING CON FIRM THAT IS THE
ALLEGATIONS ARE RIDDLED WITH
INACCURACIES BUT NOT REALLY
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS ON THE
SPECIFICS.
WE ASKED IF THAT ALLEGED CHINESE
GOVERNMENT SPY IS STILL WORKING
AT TWITTER.
THERE WAS NO ANSWER FOR US ON
THAT.
SHAREHOLDERS VOTED FOR THAT MUSK
$44 BILLION TO TAKE OVER TWILTER
TO GO AHEAD.
MUSK AS YOU KNOW IS TRYING TO
BACK OUT NOW.
THAT IS ALL GOING TO TRIAL IN A
FEW WEEKS